bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
première édition du 7 8 week end la
première édition d'une nouvelle saison
toujours plein de sorties et d'activités
à vous proposer
alors avec manic bourges est ce nous
parlerons dans un instant d'une journée
champêtre organisé par l'association des
paralysés de france met tout de suite
nous abordons les traditionnel forum des
associations si vous n'avez pas encore
choisi vos loisirs pour l'année c'est
donc le moment de le faire ce samedi 6
et dimanche 7 septembre on en parle avec
le trois invités alors bonjour à tous
alors vous allez me donner un petit
avant goût de ce qui sera proposé lors
de ces forums des as sont des
associations alors à ma droite jean-luc
le tueur me vous êtes le vice-président
de l'association verrière trois lascars
à bande à vos côtés a d'alleurs robach
professeur de danse de l'association
quentin country line dance une
association donc basé à elancourt mais
je le précise vous propose également des
cours sur la commune de trappes et enfin
stéphane hlaing responsable technique de
l'association ini monteyne franchir pour
s'affranchir
alors vous serez tous donc présent au
forum des associations dans leurs villes
respectives
donc voilà donc on va démarrer avec vous
adèle robach honneur aux dames
votre association propose de la danse
country
pouvez vous nous en dire un peu plus
alors nous sommes une association de loi
1901 donc
qui a été créée en 2009 et nous avons
des cours sur sur l'encours est sûre
trappe alors la line dance s'est
pratiqué en ligne mais aussi dans ceux
en partenaire en contrat contredanses
est donc vraiment abordable c'est elle
et abordable par tous ces 2,7 à 90 ans
et toujours sur de la musique country
après on fait peut-être un petit peu de
line de la new line comme on appelle sur
des musiques récente mais dans notre
association
vraiment c'est de la musique country
vraiment 99%
c'est que ça qui peut se pratiquer
tellement par couple alors par un couple
en cercle en ligne bien sûr et c'est
surtout aussi on a beaucoup de
d'adhérents qui arrive de des danses de
salon où il faut être accompagné de la
country vous pouvez très bien venir seul
il n'y a pas de souci vraiment on sur
place quand elle danse en couple il ya
les femmes qui jouent le rôle de l'homme
ça pose aucun problème dans les danses
en couple quel est votre demande du coup
au forum pour donner envie aux gens vont
donner envie aux gens de venir à venir
nous retrouver d'abord parce que c'est
un plaisir
vraiment on oublie tous les soucis il ya
vraiment toutes les classes sociales on
ne voit pas moi j'ai des médecins
j'ai des gens qui travaillent vraiment
voilà qui ont des métiers qui sont et on
ne voit pas on voit pas vraiment c'est
tout
et puis
on a des petits on aa les mamans et on a
les grands parents souvent donc on a des
générations alors je le rappelle votre
association donc sera représentée sur
deux forums celui des encours et de
trappes
elle encourt donc rendez vous samedi 6
septembre de 9 heures à 17 heures 30 au
complexe sportif europe et attrapes
c'est également le samedi 6 septembre de
10 heures à 18 heures au gymnase
anne marie et andré broustal alors on
passe du côté de la verrière à présent
jean-luc le tueur mais je rappelle que
vous êtes le vice-président de
l'association lasc'art à bandes alors
qu'est ce que propose votre association
alors notre association propose des
ateliers musique et danse
la raison d'un week-end par mois est en
fait cette musique c'est enfin c'est une
batucada en fait inspirée de décembre
brésilienne est donc le but c'est de
défilés régulièrement lors de carnaval
les instruments dans le cas avec
lesquels on joue donc c'est la gogo
c'est les petits instruments
le temps mort y est on a également des
gros instrument qu'on appelle des sur
dos et que l'on joue avec des baguettes
votre association des cours de musique
proposés et des cours de danse voilà
tout à fait donc pendant les week-ends
en fait
la musique et la danse sont séparés et
on trouve toujours au moins une heure
pour faire à la fois musique et danse et
préparer les défilés et l'objectif à
terme c'est de déambuler dans la rue
tous ensemble voilà leur de carnaval
d'événements sportifs ou autres
festivités
c'est important ce forum samedi pour oui
tout à fait ça va nous permettre de
recruter de nouvelles personnes et un
dessus de faire grossir la troupe de
votre côté donc je me rappelle encore
une fois c'est à la verrière que ça se
passe samedi 6 septembre également
rendez vous de 14 heures à 19 heures au
scarabée pour vous retrouver la
compagnie bien évidemment des autres
associations
allez on passe du côté de montigny le
bretonneux maintenant stéphane hlaing
vous représenter l'association franchir
pour s'affranchir
elle propose une discipline plutôt
original appelé le parcours alors qu'est
ce que c'est tout il parcourt c'est une
méthode de franchissement en fait qu'on
met en place devant les obstacles
ça peut être un obstacle
urbain dans la ville ça peut être un
obstacle naturel ça s'apparente à une
barrière s'apparente à un mur ou tout
simplement grimpé dans un arbre comme
les enfants et développer des méthodes
particulières et spécifiques à la
pratique dans ces milieux là et alors
comment ça se passe vous vous retrouvez
en groupe et vous déambulez dans la rue
parce que ça se passe vraiment milieu
urbain ou en forêt alors on se retrouve
groupe avec les adhérents d'une
association ils ont entre neuf et et
vingt ans après n'a pas forcément de b
ambühl est en fait il ya il ya une
méthode d'entraînement
on commence toujours par l'échauffement
spécifique puis après on fait un
échauffement un peu plus
on va dire non c'est plein mouvement
après l'apaisement spécifiques
on attaque le corps de séance qui
consiste à mettre des ateliers en place
et à travailler les techniques du jeu et
reprendre ce qu'ils avaient vu la veille
donc ils puissent perfectionner leur
pratique voilà c'est une association qui
existe depuis trois ans c'est ça c'est
ça et 21 octobre 2011 mais c'est assez
nouveau quand même c'est pas c'est pas
très connus comme comme discipline ça
existe depuis quand donc ces existe
depuis les années
80 fin des années 80 début des années 90
voilà et c'est paru dans des films qu'on
connaît comme banlieue 13 s'est parlé
aussi dans casino royale dans taxi de
eux aussi voilà les apparitions comme ça
où on s'en rend pas toujours compte que
c'est cette discipline à cagnes en avant
est alors quelle qualité il faut avoir
pour si les gens par exemple de ce
samedi veulent s'inscrire dans votre
association
quelles qualités particulières il faut
avoir envie faut avoir envie il faut
être faut être persévérant et je dirais
que la qualité principale est celle qui
permet de préserver de pratiquants c'est
d'être une humble d'avoir de l'humidité
en fait parce que il ya un proverbe qui
dit que l'orgueil précède la rue ni
larves ans pressé de lachute et ça va
très bien à ce sport on a faut pas trop
se croire capable 2 il faut vous dossier
de ressentir les choses avec son coeur
et avoir un pur humble très bien vous
proposer des cours des stages qu'est ce
que vous proposez dans votre association
donc cette année on propose des cours à
l'année qui auront lieu lundi et le
jeudi
les stages ne sont pas encore
déterminées et s'ils ont lieu ils auront
lieu sur la période des vacances
scolaires et en intérieur et en
intérieur mais est ce que tous les
jeunes attendent venez nombreux
et sinon les cours habituels se passe
donc en l'extérieur toujours en
extérieur humaine pendant la période
hivernale très bien et bien pour en
savoir plus sur cette discipline rendez
vous donc samedi 6 septembre encore à
montigny le bretonneux
le forum des associations s'est donc de
9h à 18h au complexe sportif pierre de
coubertin
merci à vous tous d'être venus sur notre
plateau alors avant de parler solidarité
sachez que ce week-end de nombreux
autres forum des associations se déroule
sur notre territoire
alors samedi 6 septembre ça se passe
également à saint-cyr-l'ecole à plaisir
donc voilà toutes les informations qui
s'affiche
on continue donc ensuite avec maurepas
villepreux ou encore rock one year
n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur les
sites des communes pour avoir toutes les
précisions
seule exception à la règle ce week-end
car ce n'est pas le samedi
mais le dimanche 7 septembre les
clayes-sous-bois organise également leur
forum ce sera de 10 heures à 18 heures
alors on va parler solidarité à présent
avec vous mme monique boget c'est
bienvenu alors vous êtes chargé de
mission pour la délégation évinoise de
l'association des paralysés de france et
ce samedi 6 septembre à magny les
hameaux vous proposer une soirée
champêtre à l'abbaye de port royal des
champs
alors qu'est ce que c'est alors là
soient riches inquiète c'est un grand
événement convivial qui permet de réunir
nos adhérents nos bénévoles les familles
les amis fait toutes les personnes qui
ont envie de venir faire la fête avec
nous c'est un événement qui est ouvert à
tout le monde que les gens ne nous
connaissent ou pas on peut venir
même au dernier moment s'inscrire donc
ce nivellement qui avec existe depuis
quatre ans c'est la 4ème édition que
l'on a monté avec le partenariat de la
ville de port royal des champs qui
depuis quatre ans nous prêtent leur site
donc ça c'est carrément gros davantage
parce que c'est absolument magnifique
que l'on commenté également grâce au
concours de la casse qui de au soutien
géré fine ces deux casques et du conseil
général des yvelines et on présente des
animations grâce à des partenaires comme
les vieux pistons qui est une
association de d'amoureux des vieilles
voitures qui viennent régulièrement
proposés à nos adhérents de faire des
petits tours en voiture dont 20 des
voitures à syens très agréable on a
cette année également les entreprises
marconnet qui viennent avec des handi
bike donc ils vont venir avec tout un
tas de deux vélos pousseurs de tricycles
donc pour que l'on puisse voir et tester
le matériel pour sensibiliser
sensibiliser voit là aussi on aura
également la possibilité de visiter le
musée de port royal des chats de visiter
le domaine le fameux inauguration des
fameux jardins suspendus ces voix là et
donc on à la chasse de pouvoir inaugurer
cette année des jardins suspendus c'est
un projet que bonds qui qui a été un
petit un petit peu difficile à monter
parce qu'il fallait trouver le terrain
il fallait trouver des financeurs
c'est encore la bid port royal des
champs qui nous a prêté intérêt et c'est
la fondation truffaut qui nous a aidé au
niveau financier ainsi que le conseil
général et art pour mettre en place ces
jardins qu'est ce que c'est justement ce
jour dit jardin suspendu donc c'est
désormais accessible aux cds jardins
accessibles aux personnes en situation
de handicap
en fait ce sont des bacs surélevés
les personnes même un fauteuil vienne
sos le fauteuil passe sous les bacs et
peuvent jardiner et on termine la soirée
avec un concert voilà alors d'abord en
marche
voilà donc il y aura un repas servi au
fait qui a été fait par le piano royale
de saint cyr et ensuite nous aurons un
concert qui est nous est donnée
gracieusement par l'harmonie de jussiê
très bien alors je rappelle donc c'est à
magny les hameaux à partir de 16 heures
ce samedi 6 septembre
à noter également qu'il faut compter 10
euros en prévente 12 euros sur place
et pour les enfants de moins de 12 ans
ce sera donc 5 euros merci monique
bourgeois there is notre plateau
en musique à présent si vous appréciez
l'électro ne ratez pas le festival inox
part que pour sa cinquième édition
il revient ce samedi 6 septembre à
partir de 11 heures ça se passe à chatou
sur l'île des impressionnistes
retrouvez les informations de
réservation et la programmation sur le
site inox paris.com si vous êtes
et si vous êtes plutôt au cinéma voilà
pour vous le coup de coeur de la semaine
selon l'ong de bruno mercier
gaël pineau du grenier à ciel à celle de
trappes nous présente ce long métrage
s'est activée
soyons c'est le premier long métrage de
bruno mercier et c'est en recherchant
une musique pour son film qui l'a
rencontré et ya cohen et lui a demandé
de tenir le rôle principal et yack wayne
c'est avant tout un musicien et le
compositeur il fait partie du groupe
rorschach et sont donc son tout premier
rôle après la projection ignorer nos
mini concert acoustique
il a composé la musique du film et il
viendra interpréter quelques titres en
acoustique avec sa guitare au grenier à
sel est riche
parce qu'on voudrait se sont en revanche
ça à ses côtés dans le film découvrons
aussi une jeune actrice qui s'appelle
juliette du temps qui est une comédienne
professionnelle et on l'a régulièrement
sur les planches
les deux acteurs seront donc au grenier
à sel le vendredi 5 septembre à 20h45
pensez à réserver sur notre site
www.cineagde.com
elles ont terminé cette édition avec du
sport ce week end à bois d'arcy d'abord
dimanche 7 septembre et à l'occasion de
la fête de la saint gilles
la commune organise un grand rendez vous
sportif au complexe jean moulin c'est de
10h à 16h ah ben maintenant le centre
aéronautique inaugure un tout nouveau
planeur handisport et à cette occasion
une grande journée découverte du vol à
voile est proposé à partir de 10 heures
n'hésitez pas à vous renseigner en
appelant le numéro qui s'affiche
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
nous avoir suivis prochain rendez-vous
avec l'actualité lundi dès 18 heures
d'ici là je vous souhaite un excellent
week end